et à tous donc moi c'est mustapha c'est
facile g je me suis demandée en fait
pourquoi j'étais là et c'était compliqué
donc on commence
je suis né et j'ai grandi en côte
d'ivoire et les gens me demandaient à
temps mais quand je disais ça aux gens
rient c'était jean away tchèque nom est
tu livres rien j'ai ouï oui ça existe
pardon ça existe
me voici voilà et et en fait quand je
commence à raconter plus mon histoire
c'est je suis libanais et là ça commence
à comprendre un peu plus ah ouais c'est
pour ça tu es libanais en côte d'ivoire
voilà c'est vrai ça presse mais attends
ton accent il est bizarre pourquoi c'est
pas j'explique un peu encore plus j'ai
fait mais j'ai la chance que mes parents
ont pu l'envoyer aux etats-unis en
espagne pour faire mes études
et là ça commençait à être super
compliqué quoi il vaut rien un plan
libanais états unis et l'espagne
c'est si compliqué donc vendre story
short comme on le dit en anglais des
fois je vais demander qu'est ce qui se
passait et j'ai commencé à réaliser en
grandissant qu'il y avait rien de normal
dans la vie rien n'est normal donc dès
qu'on enlève cette petite idée de la
tête que la normale les choses
commencent à se clarifier
et je pense que c'est l'histoire que je
vais raconter aujourd'hui de comment
j'ai quitté l'est
petit village aux candidats au moins
j'ai grandi qui s'appelle soubré a
jusqu'à arriver ici un télex d'abidjan
d'accord pour commencer une seconde
voilà donc ça c'est sa valeur jeudi
c'est ma raison pour laquelle je suis
ici et divine c'est quelque chose que
moi j'ai commencé l'année passée c'est
un voyage à travers le désert du sahara
et ça commençait l'année passée donc
comment j'ai quitté mon petit village de
soubré peut arriver à travers le désert
du sahara ça a commencé
moi personnellement je n'avais jamais
pensé à ça quand j'étais dans mon petit
village et j'avais jamais pensé qu'un
jour j'allais faire la photo était resté
le désert du sahara et quelque chose
d'autant coule donc comment ce que je
suis arrivé c'est que quand j'ai grandi
j'ai commencé à aller chercher ce que
moi personnellement j'aimais parce que
tu as les moyens qui étaient à where
asie tu fais ton éducation tu finis tu
viens tu bosses avec nous tu fais de la
jambe tu te maries tu fais des enfants
et voilà mais non c'est pas c'est pas ma
vie à moi donc j'ai pris du temps pour
me comprendre moi-même apprend beaucoup
de choses sur moi-même et de savoir
quelle est ma passion
donc j'ai découvert la passion qui était
la photo est en fête avec quelque chose
qui met des volets en grandissant
c'était la curiosité donc avec la
curiosité et la photographie et voilà
donc ça a commencé l'année passée qu'on
avait la gueule au mali et là tout le
monde c'était la guerre au mali on veut
pas aller au mali c'est fini et moins
chic et lajunie de mai non non je veux
voyager étude peut pas voyager parce
qu'elle est quelque chose qui se passait
dans le petit coin on ne pouvait pas le
resterai dans un docu sur un seul pays
donc j'ai voulu voyager je voulais
voyager et j'en avais marre des gens qui
me disaient tu peux pas aller dans tel
coin ou tel coin parce que tu pouvais
pas parce que c'était pas c'est très
bien donc moi je me suis dit vous savez
quoi
le salage aime bien il ya tellement de
gens qui vivent là bas en fait il
fallait réaliser que tant que ea les
gens qui vivent
on peut aller si les gens à la vie si
les gens y vivent normalement
moi aussi je peux aller les visiter et
vivent donc ce qui s'est passé c'est que
j'ai décidé de visiter le désert du
sahara grâce à ma curiosité mais aussi
elle est une autre chose qui manquait
nous tous on fait les voyages super cool
on est allé à thaïlande on est allé au
burkina on a fait le nigeria on a fait
l'afrique du sud on a fait les états
unis mais ce qui est différent c'est
qu'il faut partager
donc on se cherche d'où même la
curiosité
mon amour pour la photographie ma
passion pour le voyage est aussi je
voulais partager ça avec le lèche du
monde entier donc ce constat fallait
planifier ce voyage planifié comme on
partage avec les gens ont créé la page
facebook sahara jimmy est en fait
c'était un rêve pour moi mon frère
c'était d'au moins très une image
complètement différente de la région
du sale que les gens n'avaient jamais vu
avant donc l'intention était là on a vu
des filles lou avait des oasis et des
chameaux des du ca partout mais non ça
c'est pas bon ça à moi bon ça là moi
c'est ça le salarié ben que je vais vous
montrer grâce à sa carrosserie mais que
vous pouvez suivre aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux sur facebook et autres donc déjà
ça relève du mythe ça commence avec les
photos de paysages en fait qu'on dit
bamako les gens n'ont pas nécessairement
cette idée au super bowl le hic est
clean qui est bien avec des structures
un peu bizarre mais super intéressante
donc c'était un moins d'aller dans ces
coins là pour le montrer aux gens ce qui
existait mais pourquoi en bois pourquoi
pas un autre ami qui fait la photo qui
fait ça en fait
moi je suis connecté à mon pays je suis
connecté à cette région et quand on dit
il faut penser au futur il faut montrer
une image positive c'est pas quelqu'un
d'autre qui va venir faire ça c'est
moins c'est moi qui va le faire si moi
j'ai les capacités
si moi j'ai l'âme ans pour le faire je
vais le faire pourquoi pas moi donc ça
c'était une raison pour laquelle je fais
ça par johnny est non seulement je
prenais des photos de paysages et tout
mais c'était les gens en fait que je
rencontrais qui faisait toute la
différence
samajam insee tunisie algérie niger
burkina faso ma vie éco d'ivoire plus de
12000 km mais il ya plusieurs manières
de faire deux mille kilomètres
on peut prendre un avion et ça passe un
seul vol ça c'est pas mal mais non moi
je voulais mélanger avec les gens jouent
blairon
dans la vie quotidienne des gens donc je
plais les transports publics sans hôtel
donc je dormais chez les gens pendant
une période de temps où les gens
pensaient qu'il y avait la guerre au
mali je suis allé au mali j'avais pas de
guerre il y avait des gens qui étaient
super sympa qui était super souriant qui
étaient accueillants chez qui j'ai passé
des lumières vieux comme invités bien
sûr et j'ai vu la beauté des gens mais
il y avait tellement de choses super
beau et avec tout ça je découvrais les
choses super caché que moi même je
savais pas que ça existait quand par
exemple avec ronnie qui sautent
incroyable si si si c'est fou ça je n'ai
jamais pensé que les crocodiles zone
mais pas l'ombre m'avait jamais dit ça à
l'école on nous a pas dit ça je pense
pas d'école m'avait dit que c'était pas
possible
voilà donc c'était le choc de ma vie
quoi pour moi c'est grâce à ce que moi
j'ai trouvé en moi même donc ma passion
j'ai suivi ma passion j'ai suivi mon
amour pour le voyage g c'est un succès
fou ait offert quoi que j'apporte des
photos tu as voyages et c'est ça et puis
tu as su lee les gens pensaient que je
suis fou et ça se passe gonflé voulait
pas que j'aille à sarah ladjmi il ya des
gens qui ont dit c'est impossible mais
vous savez quoi
on est différent chaque personne est
différent et vivre sa différence
c'est ce qu'il nous fait
briller comme si je veux ça passe ça
nous fait prier on est différent soyez
différents inaba honte d'être différent
parce que c'est votre différence qui va
montrer aux gens ces choses que
eux-mêmes ne serait pas existé et avec
vous même votre amour votre passion
suivez continuer à allaiter jamin et
vous allez montrer des choses au monde
qu eux-mêmes ne savait pas qui existait
il peut - c'est avec ces choses là qu'on
va arriver à un habillage en 2007 2057
qui est incroyable et voilà merci